once you're sitting in your here are all
the things you may not do you may not
lean back your chair seats are equipped
with this function but not because
you're supposed to actually use it the
recline option on the seat is just there
as a test to see who is a sociopath if
you hit the button you fail the test you
may not eat any food that gives off a
strong smell or makes any kind of sound
so this rule basically rules out all
food except for white plain white bread
is all you're allowed to eat on the
plane if you're sitting next to me
anyway you may not speak to the person
next to you unless you're spoken to but
they also are following the same rule
which means that nobody's speaking at
all if you're in the middle seat as I've
explained in the past you have no
privileges and no human rights no no you
are worse than a second class citizen
you don't exist this means that you
don't have permission to use either of
your armrests your superiors on the end
get both of their armrests you get
nothing you lose you're also not allowed
to inconvenience the aisle seat by
getting up to use the bathroom you must
sit there legs together arms folded head
Bound in silence for the duration of the
flight